there's no way I want to welcome you to
our 300th episode we've done more but
let's just say this is our three who's
just so British 300 right and yeah and
three thousand does he goes we're
counting from the Fox Sports days till
now we decide to go off on our own yeah
flourish oh yeah yeah we spread we grew
our wings we jumped out that nest again
we begin sortie ah you're [ __ ] on
them ah I believe it amen no I like
those guys random on there but don't
hate them it's okay where's the 300
episode and this reminds me but how many
have we done though be think God how
many did we do on our own with a mic in
your in your I mean I've got she we've
probably done 500 episodes that's what
I'm thinking right why fondo well we did
we were doing well into well over a year
before we get went to Fox I think that
yeah year and a half yeah you know so
long time in a long time I've known you
a long time and I wish I could sing a
song about you you don't sing anymore
yeah oh you got a fool that old you stop
singing cuz your brains all [ __ ] up
don't say that don't make that noise
about me he's so much more fun when you
were younger in person getting old and
rickety and your teeth bother me the
[ __ ] out of me I was supposed to wear my
trace tonight today and I forgot them in
my kitchen set my wife a text and I
forgot my trays boring boring I mean
metal braces what metal braces yeah you
know what 300 signifies dude you and me
blacks holding back the [ __ ]
onslaught of people trying to topple us
and we're holding the gates were at the
gates of we're the sport at the gates of
hell no over they've got with the
Spartans protecting the gates of Sparta
close their mother Molly yes they're
bottling
their ma Polly and what does Thermopylae
mean Thor's hometown very close very
close it means hot weather hot ghee you
know I hate not familiar
you know what I'm gonna know history
we're here at the hot gates you and I
with our Chancellor damaged I feel like
you're the guy with the eye patch who
tells the stories and I yeah and I'm the
the warrior what no you're the guy with
the eye patch where we're about to all
die and he's like come here little [ __ ]
no you know look what you have you seen
the movie yes where's like tonight we
dine in Hell
yes and he's like come here [ __ ] with
the eye patch now you're gonna go back I
don't have it hi doc you got a tale to
tell my friend no my very well this is
what I was all but yeah he's like you
have a gift of talking not fighting
don't tell me this I want you to look at
me and go we will darken the clouds with
our we will darken the sky with our
arrows now watch we will darken the
clouds without your are the skies the
skies yeah we will darken the skies with
our heroes i watch what i patch be ready
then we shall have to fight in the dark
but no you're the guy why you don't
fight yes I [ __ ] do well I don't want
to be to go to the eyepatch
alright night you're the guy who's like
you me mask no I'm not let me part a
300-mile might lift your shoes like
you're out ah you want the eyepatch it
will be bubble but I'd be lethal with my
sword date I'd be the dancer they call
me the dance you'd be fat you could be
Fassbender uh-huh they call me the
stinging dancer says that said sit they
call me they call me Brian cut you to
ribbons Callan well cut you to rid the
the Persian in this whole thing don't
Osiris yes Cyrus how about that Cyrus
was I've got that den of [ __ ]
rehearsing with cities Cersei yeah I was
oh did I love that movie oh that that
movie was let's forget can we get honest
that movie was what's the word oh yeah
great
through-and-through a movie me and my
buddy watched it and he turned to me and
he was in use 40 I mean the way he goes
greatness I was like no yeah
then CrossFit and really that really
spiked CrossFit because that they had a
lot of the Spartan CrossFit workouts yes
funny story about Butler this is the
talk around town is the hole so like
that's fast banners big movie
that's a bunch of guys they got shredder
Fassbender was in there I didn't know
that beam oh [ __ ] yes first break huh
I'm right right so you know so all the
all the 300 guys there's a ton of them
they had this trainer had take him
through the the CrossFit workout so the
shreddin had the strict diet and Gerard
Butler was just showing up like out of
shape and he's like Wednesday when are
we actually shooting and he's like dude
you got to do the workouts he's like no
think you got you got to look like a
[ __ ] Spartan Angus when are we
shooting I'll be ready
he's like the [ __ ] does that mean sure
enough shows up Wow cuz he was gonna do
warrior he was one of the guys would you
finish story they're dead so because he
was gonna do warrior and he he was one
of the guys that Gavin really wanted but
he just when what I heard he just didn't
want to do the words I don't want to get
back into shape because I'm a lot of
that glass if you're sachi like [ __ ]
that Riley's such a beast right looks
great in that though goddamn but then
three guesses bar time a lot of it you
know they're spray paint you know it's
crazy though I wonder if the Spartans
back then were acting that shredded I'm
super skeptical here boys especially
when you look at like the statues of
like great men back then because a they
really have the resources be they just
didn't know they didn't eat as much as
you know they weren't like fueling their
bodies all the time I'm sure it was
clean food obviously not processed I
doubt they're that big and jacked all
that well I I think that when and you
know like we would been left laughed out
of town because if you have a fat dick
it was like a bad thing you know that
well small dicks when all things they
would high-five if you had a big dick
like no better sure when you make sure
when you made statues you want to keep
them you didn't have a huge dick cuz
when you carve the statue out of said it
was always considered you put either a
fig leaf over it or you had a small
tasteful dick you didn't have that but
that point but those were like the the
posters for them like that's your that's
your magazine that year TMZ magnums so
when you see a small dick that's the
cool thing so if you had a fat hog you
got laughed out of town there's one god
who's laughing now Sparta there's one
God who Oh
massive dick you know us he was a
demigod Achilles no he had a massive
dick pan please bring up the god you say
had had a pan pan okay and and he was
the guy that hey origins would meet in
the forest yeah the god Pan I take a
look at this take a look at his [ __ ]
him PA n yeah there you go
now he's a goat he's a goat man well
he's a Satan man yeah oh yeah I get
horns and he had [ __ ] the
hindquarters of a goat and in a lot of
statues have him with a [ __ ] raw Dola
I mean a low-paid Obama well areas gay
no he [ __ ] goats any [ __ ] well not
there that's the small smallsy oh no
look at that yeah yeah he's now all
that's weak brings up is set of balls
right now the hands dick we gotta do if
you want a google pan or Pam chin pan
hey God Benny played a flute
there you go that's where you go hold up
we're comin at you yeah look at this he
was big look at the ultimate Satan did I
ride in his his own dick like a bullet
and feel to see this chin yeah God dog
riding his own dick like a broomstick
that's when you know that's Satan Brian
that's not him no that's that's the god
Pan that should be the god Pan
scrub at all oh boy it was a Randy he
was a hornier yeah there you go there
you go look at those hindquarters he's
got hooves which means he can run his
ass off and he can [ __ ] and you got
laughed out of town if you had that fat
hog that's right even I where would we
go
I know start our own well I'd love to be
I'd love to have the hindquarters of a
strong Ram I want I'm gonna back that
seems like the that's the statue is on a
small waist a big ass and our [ __ ] is
enormous right here yeah I don't I don't
you know that Nick has lungs and an echo
that's a dog I'm telling well it was
frowned upon a field of fat hog oh so
back then Wow not if you were pan not if
you were a little maiden who walked in
here like I just want to pick some
mushrooms and he was like hello was I
what you smell ruddy and he's like how
about this and she was like I don't know
okay well uh
in smoke you can smoke your [ __ ] weed
out of his dick man that gets you my
going not me that's too much it does me
not me I want to smoke that dog go smoke
that dick yeah look at that look at that
blow that flute you [ __ ] hey speaking
of smoking dick our originals dick diver
tees drop tonight along with the jerseys
nice can we get a can we get you and I
and in that in the likeness will someone
make a statue of the two of us with with
it with impalas also being put on the
table here but I don't say impossible
but realistic yeah yeah nice and
realistic I mean fat yeah well I say fat
I mean like that like whoops whoops ha
like distracting look I'm like what the
[ __ ] is that you die like yeah it is
yeah I my spine of a snorkeling cuz the
dick diver that's right and he as in as
in I got a and I got a drawing board
because I certified people in dick
diving yeah yeah I'm like the Jacque
Cousteau of dick can you make Brennan
I'm we want to be regular but with the
hindquarters of a strong RAM of a goat
with with just just to ten-hut dong yeah
but nothing 10 we're not [ __ ] each
other we're like no we're like no wait
hold on well no yeah I'm gonna take
weird no no we're - we're just friends I
know we're not like Batman Robin with
fat hog okay but why did nothing like
we're not [ __ ] well why did you have
to bring that up in the first player man
people come up so we don't get no he
would go Photoshop Steve or Martin or
gonna tell them some weird be bigger
you're gonna have a big hole that my dog
fits in you know what get Brenda vagina
don't know me I don't know and have him
peeling his peach
oh why hey make sure when you do it yeah
you give Brian metal braces I'm getting
high that you forgot my turn also rip is
hair back I thought my hair is cute I'm
kidding it gets wet and it looks good
and then it dries I got to start putting
product in my hair I've had it you don't
use product though I got to start let's
try to use a new one I'm gonna talk
about here I guess 10% a let's do it
I started switching over to hair spray
really yeah I blow dry it out I do the
blowout and Jersey Shore and I use some
hairspray you blow-dry your hair yeah
the shower that's what I got going on
you know the big day some meaning
they'll do a blow that's impressive
there's a certain discipline to
appearing well and I don't really I use
you know what you just don't give a [ __ ]
I get a little say you gave up no come
on I work out all the time because you
like to work out you don't do it for
love I want you guys about my core yeah
you he did that good cuz I've been
training you did that it's new for me
and I really like it
you kept blowing up my phone today
because I say either link to my
retrospective I love that video yeah I
can't when does that come out tonight on
fight network so watch this watch it
because it's worth it and it's and I I
was hundred in America I think it's on
Amazon iTunes I forget where else cuz
we're not fighting networking this in
the States so I think it's on Amazon
iTunes exists see I know you and I know
the stories but I don't I did that stuff
right I didn't know the I think when you
see it nice and when you see what you
went through in the Ultimate Fighter but
what I what I didn't realize to the
extent was how little training you had
like you did not train I mean when you
see when you won the ultimate fighter
are you almost did it when you were you
were peppering Rory really big country
space yeah dude you had probably been
fighting for about I mean it correct me
if I'm wrong but like maybe 15 16 months
I'd maybe 20 minutes of actual fight
time it's so nuts you know you came to
the game at 24 25 and you'd never fought
really no and and and then you you win
Golden Gloves in Colorado after boxing
for 10 minutes and then you well and
then and then you're now you're training
with Shane and these monsters but you
really didn't you were in a gym where
you were actually training jiu-jitsu and
all that stuff for 15 16 months yeah no
that's crazy and then you you believed
in your own athleticism but then to see
you beat Gabriel Gonzaga who's a true
vet and you did it in in three rounds
you know banging it out beat the break
though beat the breaks out of him what
did getting behind your jab and all that
then you beat cro cop after that was the
most brutal thing I'd ever seen
it was a brutal fight
oh my god when he broke your nose in how
many places 16 yeah I mean stitches
everywhere and just you know so you kind
of went through it's really really I'm
not gonna spoil it cuz it's important
it's interesting to hear but people know
that you kind of realized that you were
very athletic that you'd beaten these
legends and these monsters and that you
were very gifted and surprised everybody
but you also knew that because you just
know that life matter of time before you
ran into a big nog or someone with his
excitable that's a cheat I said I
realized my cheat code was gonna run out
so [ __ ] amazing yeah it's amazing I
was so happy cuz the UFC grant them
access to all the the fight footage yeah
which I you know all these interviews
I've done they you know they really
don't have the exact right cuz you can
talk over the fight and talk about
nailing the Ultimate Fighter footage the
first fight with Chase Gormley you can
take you can take a punch right to your
[ __ ] face you got punched square in
the face by cro cop you got elbowed a
ton of times and had your nose shattered
you got [ __ ] overhand righted by big
country twice twice before he hit you
behind the ear and that awkward which is
impossible to defend against and
everybody goes out and they get down
here but you do [ __ ] shots that spun
your head and came right back like here
you go i mean you know it's kind of
remark about that that was the one thing
that i came away with it I was like this
[ __ ] had very little training
you're thrown in there because I was so
scared yeah man the [ __ ] wouldn't be but
I I then began again tossed in with Navy
SEALs so you've just played video yeah
if you had had if you had if you would
be completed 20 you'd be a world
champion there's no power I don't know
brother who knows who cares I'll talk
about a big round break down your stairs
talking about how like I used to and you
know this a little bit if you want to
get me to shut up and I'm a Chatty Cathy
asked me about my fight career yeah I
don't like talking about and for the
longest I was I was more embarrassed
about he shouldn't be well I mean while
I'm saying is like out for a long time I
know you know like let's say your goal
was to be a comedian yep and you you
know since you were you know whatever
that was the goal freaking to be a
comedian and for whatever reason you
you're not up at the Comedy Store you're
not at the Laugh act
you have no specials you can't sell take
it then everywhere you go people know
that and they ask you about it yeah I
mean like [ __ ] and when the goal is to
get to to get a penny store to get you
know to and for me the goal when we
started was world champion yeah I was
ranked 15 I've been ranked number 10
number not just depends where you want
what poll you look at I've been ranked
the top 10 you know how that feels
exactly like being ranked number two
yeah unless you were the champion it's
all the same so for me I viewed it as a
failure cuz mission was never complete
so and for the longest I don't know you
know when we started this podcast I
didn't really want to talk about
fighting because I had this negative
connotation with it a little bit and
then now I just think because I'm such a
different Lane I can look back in
retrospective and you know and I'm I'm
successful in this other field now it
depends what you wanna call success but
I'm just doing something different now I
can look back and go yeah that was cool
for the first literally price that and
that just happened the past two weeks
maybe oh cool man
yeah yeah well for me that you know the
idea that you in any way would be and I
get it I mean you said very high
standards of yourself I remember you
looked at me one time very quietly and
went I'm gonna get the belt I got this
be well I got this and I believed you
that kind of confidence when you had you
know so little training you were
fighting guys who had been fighting
their whole life you were fighting guys
who had been high high level wrestlers
of high level national effort wrestlers
um you know guys who'd been doing more
time and had thirty fights and you know
more than that their whole life so the
idea that in any way you would feel
embarrassed I mean again it's very
important to keep in mind when you were
faced off with big country you had been
fighting and training for about 16
months that's the truth though right
yeah tough go right so so please sign up
for though I wouldn't change anything
I'm not saying you wouldn't change
anything but I'm saying that that it's
it's it's pretty remarkable that you
were able to accomplish you know I'm
glad I didn't get started earlier
because of your head trauma or what yeah
head travel who knows what route I would
down I think my background from football
and training it was such a higher level
in a lot of these fighters at the time
it got me to where I was that so much
faster also a grinder man you also break
dude yeah yeah I mean you you you are
the way I can American not imagine
because it was so obvious that you were
the guy who was never going to break and
then you were able to prove your cardio
you know not getting tired and stuff
there was a lot of that I haven't seen
part two but I think they really sparked
one tonight no I don't know if they do
it the next night or the next week same
time and part two is more about I talked
a little bit about the fighters
association stuff and then just what I'm
doing now I think part one also shows
you just how brutal it was how [ __ ]
truly yeah most of the so it was a
private link the guys sent to me working
fight networks we're like what the [ __ ]
but I sent to everyone close in my life
and most my family cried I don't Joe
like Joe started crying just it was so
BrewDog get realize it was good I got
emotional yeah cuz to see that I was
watching in my slingshot like a queer I
was watching my slingshot because they
sent me a link oh here it is from one
see I just got done working out and on
Zach I probably should sign off on it
before they hear it so I just went there
and yeah I get emotional me oh yeah me
too because what a journey the journey
and the brutality and to see and I know
you really well and to see you dealing
with that that like you're your [ __ ]
eyes stitched up with like 20 stitches
your nose six broken in 16 places
imagine your your imagine imagine
because that's not you so your your
[ __ ] face your mouth split to [ __ ]
you know you you're concussed you're you
know it was and then like after getting
knocked out and talking to the guys and
having to hang around the [ __ ] job
man
Oh Sean what that was worth and just and
this is and oh and by the way at that
point you had no options you know at
that and I remember worrying about you I
were worrying about you all the time
because I liked you so much when we were
younger when we were when we were boys
boys but my biggest worry was always
because I knew you you were special you
were smart and all that but I just and I
have so much respect for fighting but I
was always
well did you do what the [ __ ] does he do
you know and then the watch you know the
podcast and stand-up and all that it's
been you know it's always exciting but
man I mean nobody died yes young it made
me think about anybody who's young who
feels like they have no options at least
just do just it's all gonna do it do it
hard do it full yeah and you did yeah it
found that something happened the result
real scary though to also all that [ __ ]
riding on you know you choosing the
toughest guy in the house to fight
because of one little thing no you saw
one little crack yeah oh man really
really cool weird journey we journey
journey man journey well yeah and I wish
I could sing a song based on that weird
journey he's big his head is shaved your
nose is different too I looked a little
bit different I've got I went Halle
whitey and I got nose I know in my ears
weren't [ __ ] up my ears thing you
[ __ ] up to probably after Gonzaga I
just make fun of guys the cauliflower
and all somebody just went like [ __ ] you
that comes from just getting punched
near that get from balls just non-stop
not obsessed with jiu-jitsu I was doing
so much and finally just went to yeah
there we are do you miss jiu-jitsu I
still do it with Heather on Saturday
mornings every now and then but no no
I'm actually anything about well it's
just it's I can't put energy into it
yeah I have too much yeah you just can't
put energy you're creating what he's
over I what's so funny is when I was in
my going through like fight crew you'd
go do you think you're still gonna like
box and work out when you're done I went
I would do jujitsu for the rest of my
life which I well in some former fast a
bit you're like ah I don't think you
will
I was like you're foolish yeah yeah it's
just no well you're you're gonna drive
you have a lot of work to do in other
places and you're creative and you're
doing other things so sometimes you know
I think all of us enjoy discovery you
know just part of like creativity is
discovery there's no mini
yeah getting better at something and
seeing your body change but also your
mind change discovering kind of the
something is a mystery usually a
language so jiu jitsu zijn language
very intricate language and once you
start to be able to speak that language
and you get a sense of what it would be
like to speak that line was even better
like well now yeah and that now there's
a desert of mystery which is comedy and
your stand-up comedy what what like you
know in the beginning you were like what
I don't know I mean I don't even know
I'll tell stories I'm not a comedian
yeah you know and now now now you're
starting to you're with all of us have
been doing a long time you're in it and
you're like you're getting it you're
like oh I see how you put bits together
I see how you know and and that becomes
and that requires a lot of energy yeah
that requires a lot of your you know
yeah yeah I told you that story where I
was my sister and my mother
um this is such a full circle thing for
me and my dad but my mother says yeah
Brian's here we're all together and he's
here but he's not really here because I
was daydreaming and they were talking to
me about shopping or something right
yeah and my father goes excuse me how
about leaving him alone he's in his own
brain and that's how he comes out with
jokes and that's how he makes his living
the bill it's true it is yeah yeah it's
true yeah you know it sounds like I'm
you know not to be a dick but that's
what I'm interested in and that is what
I make okay if I look like I'm
daydreaming I'm probably twerking yeah
Jenny's hard opinion yeah it's hard to
improve we can understand it yeah you
know it's weird and again going back to
fighting like when we're when we first
started playing podcast when I said I'm
down to do it but not if I have to just
talk about fighting you're like all
right yeah I remember that because I
wanted to do a fight centric podcast I
didn't want to do it and then you know
now I love where we're at now I have the
big brown breakdown of this we go I
cover everything and and I'd like I've
never appreciate fighting more I'm balls
deep in boxing yeah balls deep and makes
martial art you have a distance from it
what do you what do you like about what
are you watch about it um what else I
ask because Andre Agassi hated tennis
right he's like uh now you you know he
didn't like that no look at me
I hated tennis yeah he was father made
him play all the time and he couldn't
for I think like ten years and now he's
always watching it well John never for a
while there I would watch it and like oh
god because I would I would look at the
white the guys would go through in the
loss and devastation but those were my
own demons and then securities now I
watch it like I understand like for a
lot of guys
for there you can get through it there
now to deal with it obviously you I
don't think they're compensated right
they're gonna deal with some brain
trauma potentially but yeah you know it
is what it is yes
yeah um you know I love it I don't miss
anything anymore
nothing when there's a like Matt
material doesn't watch anything he
doesn't I know a lot of fighters who
book you talk about fights like who
Donald Cerrone doesn't know fighters I
copy oh yeah that was the same way how
do you not know Howell doesn't don't do
know who he's fighting he goes in if you
watch video the guy he's fighting soon
that kids a monster there's a lot of
guys who they dose just when you're so
consumed it but even when I was fighting
I wouldn't miss the fight I'd watch
everything really yeah yeah I love the
sport man it's a yeah that boxing I love
it too yeah I love it
thanks man thanks sweetie Thanks beat I
[ __ ] beat the brakes off a Luke
Rockhold last night yesterday not last
night but he didn't do yeah he put his
feet in my gym and had gloves on and we
danced around a little bit
dance lock him up a little bit i socked
in the [ __ ] he doesn't have a fight you
know I wonder if I was gonna fight
Whitaker next if we're kids healthy well
Whitaker's the champ and then biz beings
fighting GSP so I'd be curious if Luke
should be ready to go for that November
4th card because if GSP are Bisbing for
whatever reason I think there's a good
chance they get they don't cleared
medically right Google should ha he's
training he knows he knows that yeah
you're not dumb dude he knows that
there's a potential if anyone falls out
he'd be right there yeah he was just in
the gym doing strength conditioning
Whitakers uh you know that's a good
fight for oh yeah stylistically yeah um
obviously the left hooks an issue for me
needs to address and Whitaker's the left
hook from [ __ ] down under which could
be problems for Luke really yeah and and
when it gets quicker than Luke he's got
it he seems a guy he's got a lot of
speed Whitaker yes he's the fastest
straight up striker in the division
really yeah that's why so good he's he's
a little undersized but he's quick as
[ __ ] great takedown defense and hits
like a Mack truck that's why that's why
he's got that much eyes the jam yeah
internship with us raise a chair I think
he's you know
probably the best 185 in the world
really
yeah he's right there you put your
glutes right don't get me wrong Luke's
[ __ ] right there but after watching
Luke's fight against branch and I'm
assuming there was more Ringwraiths he
didn't look great right you know one day
he took a lot of shots let me take the
same shot that he took from branch
against Whitaker you night you're not
making out alive
Wow he's that talented Jesus but Luke's
a monster you know yeah 20 matter I mean
you can 1a 1b just well depending on the
night dependent fluke is ring rust if he
addresses those left hook issues stuff
like that he's a big he's kind of you
rain [ __ ] walking around to 15 to 12
he needs to go to light heavyweight well
he's thinking about that he so this yeah
he's referred to DC goes to heavy right
yes yes because you know the clear
partner has been [ __ ] tasty trains
with Cain Cain's Vic all the one guy
gives him you know he said well all of
them but if you you know Cain's older
DC's older rock cold you know with 85
being held up yeah don't put some life
in the light heavyweight well five you
look at lion gusts to seven be an
interesting you that'd be a tough one
for me yes the region yes eyes but you
look at everyone else I like rock holds
chances better great he does everything
great yeah grappling wrestling striking
he's long very much a phenomenal cardio
game I you know I if you went to light
heavy right now I'd put him top three
top four yeah he compete with anyone but
Dustin and off CDC would give him some
prong right but after that I think you'd
beat everybody yeah I think you'd clean
shop on those demand I was immersed I
think two or three in the world yeah
I've heard stories from other people
about I think they've sparred and stuff
like who Rockhold nosed Amir I don't
want to speak out of tool that I've
heard from a third-party that he became
de que yes so I think yeah all right
well maybe was down in Florida I'm not
sure but I just know oh yeah in Florida
in Florida now working with and I think
I've heard from the third party that he
does just working with uh [ __ ] the the
Dutch fella Rufus sorry booth let me
move who's brilliant
oh my god anywho yeah I wish that again
I mean Henry hoofed is
a high-level math as far as striking him
in imbrue fees or the two highest what
about Matt Hume is Matt Hume a huge
reason obviously Mighty Mouse is what he
is and you know a phenomenal athlete but
they call madam Yoon Hyun the wizard
would that be something that he's good
with light weights and that doesn't mean
it would necessarily transfer with
bigger people
I don't know well he worked with uh well
no that's someone else um I don't know
it's hard to tell cuz they don't have a
lot of like a deep roster right but you
have the greatest of all time with my
name se he's so good at flying like
there's no one even close I saw I think
there's the UFC like what's next for my
mouse who should he finally put Pettis
they put Sahu toe and then they put a
Joey Benavides I'm like none of the
above
yeah I don't think you'd fight any of
them unless he just wants to put the
record so out of four well who would he
fight you want to see him fight by the
winner of TJ Cody but yeah that'd be
really fascinating those guys are big
man there yeah baby but TJ's I mean DJ
so talented they do a catch rate maybe
would he do it does he is that is that
the next thing would have to be I don't
know i have no idea i don't know he
hasn't really spoken about or anything
like that i don't know what he wants to
do no idea yeah well you had a good
dinner though with Russell yeah we had a
fun time he and his buddy Cory he was a
photographer and his other buddy miles
good guys fun just a lot of laughs it
was easy out here just trade makes I'm
sure he's out here doing he was doing
some photography stuff he was doing some
yeah I think he was doing some modeling
stuff some some showbiz [ __ ] and then
and then just training getting you know
stay in shape you know and you know had
a good meal via Bennett oh I love I love
bringing people have never been there
and solution here yeah one of the guys
from box when I saw this morning his
name's Ryan he just bought a Porsche
target anyways but he was at scopa or
not scope of the event yeah so right now
it's white truffle season which means we
have to go and so white truffles and I
was trying to say I was trying explain
Corey who's great he's a photographer
and he's a surf photographer high-level
surfers
and he good-looking kid you know just
all just exciting the food and I said
and he goes my favorite thing in the
world you guys had mentioned white
truffles and I go yeah that's very
expensive
yes favorite thing in the world he goes
my favorite thing in the world is white
truffle oil and I go white truffle oil
huh so what they'll do is truffles are
so expensive let me give you an example
they're about they're about when you get
one mushroom so twenty-six hundred to
three thousand dollars a pound
what yeah look up it might even be
announced but they're but I know that
one mushrooms about $1,100 $1,100 and
surround ball this big it's $1,100 and
that's and that's what you pay as a
store girl in the yeah there you go
rich is commanding six thousand ten
thousand per pound yes ten thousand
dollars per pound so it's as expensive
or more expensive than gold or almost or
whatever let me see it what the [ __ ]
truffle looks like those white mushroom
yeah so that's what they look like by
the way and they're they're hard they're
very hard and please understand
everybody that do you know why they're
so expensive and do you know how you get
them well you go to Kabul about six feet
under the ground oh now now you use
traditionally you would use pigs because
pigs have a mouth that's right well
piggy dig dig problem is when that pig
gets that sense eating all of them and
yank the giant pig off no the pigs love
truth it's a problem so now they use
German Shorthaired Pointers and they're
there's a season for the white truffle
vert I think it's about six weeks or so
now that right there that would cost you
eleven are they delicious uh we're gonna
go we're gonna go well no let us go up
your friend of is truffle well we can
cuz Fabrizio will hook us up it's white
truffle season once again and what we do
is we go ahead and have the white corn
ravioli with the white truffles he
looked at me and I said when we visit we
can do that tonight I said to him I go
can I go to San Jose over the weekend
Thursday Friday Saturday improv you're
you told I'm you're in Utah when we come
back now listen I go take your white oil
story and get the [ __ ] out get get it
out of your oil story up your ass get
your white truffle oil pedestrian story
get it up stick it right up your ass and
bait it out of your camera out cuz I'm
gonna cover my dick in truffle that's
right shove it in your mouth
go do me a favor I want you to shave
white truffles on the white corn ravioli
and he about had a ship that he
literally goes instead of hard times you
stay well I go everything else we can't
go to truffles well everybody is cuz I
had that thing everybody everyone's in
the truck you're gonna be well I know
but I'm not gonna like geek out over
you're off you're gonna geek out because
I'm a camera guy keep that or the
truffles and so did Luke and so did
Miles they went like this they went what
wait what they were like you think
they're starving stuff and I knew that
would happen
knew that would happen cuz it's it's
it's a such a unique taste now there's
black truffles too right black truffles
not as good very very fun hey you know
what they're fun they're fun
yeah but they're nice gives the white
truffles no no that's hey look a Honda's
at night a traje Trump so you don't so
you prefer the white truffle over the
black truffle you fraid in this case and
in this case Marais cyst and the white
truffle is worth more you've read in
this case the white is better than the
black there I said it
yeah I'm sorry you like your Duff career
look I listen listen black truffles
that's a nice dude that's a nice [ __ ]
Honda it's very reliable well but just
hit me on there black truffle you can
dance you get aesthetic you give us
hip-hop
you have grape soda can you not do that
black Jeff that's actually not what I'm
saying what I'm trying to say is
compared the black truffle crazy
athletic no C shredded nope I'm gonna
ask redden ya know you're getting racial
now I'm not trying to get that racial
I'm just sex where you were going levels
to this game when it comes white truffle
intelligence smarter no I want out of
this podcast I'm talking about Trump no
you're not I'm saying if you've got a
Honda white ruffle work actually I'm
worthy ethic Pendley Sport GT that's did
that quite well yeah the white truffle
is is a delicacy beyond delicacies does
what what it's not that it's why it's
just that it's a specific kind of taste
bro because white bro but you you know
what you fell for my [ __ ] truffle
trap we
exposes some bits for being a [ __ ]
racist I like black Trump once you go
March in Charlottesville you son while I
didn't shake your [ __ ] pelicans come
two eyes out on it and then that mate oh
and [ __ ] a pitch watch me I prefer
black truffle you do this you know I
like you know I like black truffles yeah
you know goddamn well if I have any pick
in the world I'll take a leash your keys
you fell for my [ __ ] truffle he's a
lot like Rihanna bout for the old
truffle trap you know I like Rihanna
races monk not I want black truffle in
my life doesn't like her hi I'm looking
for his suite you popular and you'd
still love Rihanna she's she cuts
through all the race that girl is eating
a ton of truffles I got racism in a bit
right now and I approve rally got fit
all right white truffle seasons not
afraid of that white truffle season huh
you don't think realloc can afford some
[ __ ] white troubles got some money I
would scale how do you know it's white
truffle season though we didn't come out
like it stroll see yeah it comes around
how off oh so when you ever you're at a
really good restaurant like the advance
there they go that's about trouble you
go they go they stop and they go it's
truffles we have white truffles it's
like you've eaten trolls and that means
that means that your pasta dish that you
have that carved on or that your meat
that goes up how much it's gonna it's
gonna run you with a couple flakes of
white truffles it's cuz it's gonna run
you about a hundred and twenty dollars
[ __ ] you and your head and hey paint
with a smoker be still face if I come to
your restaurant and I get the standard
meatball with marinara sauce and you
toss those devil white truffle white
privilige truffles on top of my chairs
shave and shave them shave and then you
perk up another hundred dollars onto my
bill you pay I'm gonna steal all your
truffle Hey and I store in the kitchen
yeah I'm only into black truffles listen
I'm not black truffle take care of black
truffles and get that go to McDonald's
cuz we got that so racing no you said
take your black truffles go to stop no
you said watch take your black truffles
and dump hot sauce I did not say that
bro
Wow this into a 5k whatever Brian
enjoy your [ __ ] wine apologize for
anybody
go enjoy your white truffles no nah man
listen man sir it's an experience
hey so there where do they grow mat
though so over like California really
there's there's a couple of places
believe it or not it's all Italy it's
all Italy and there's some Croatian
Google top places to grow white truffle
it's Italy the black I think it's Genoa
place like that's Italy and then there's
Umbria and places like that I think but
it's Italy and then there's uh and then
there's Croatia and maybe some parts of
Spain propane let's go truffle hunt
I think France but I don't think Spain I
think France it's gotta be you know
Piedmont Italy okay
Piedmont a llamar de marche de Marseille
and family friend moments yeah okay keep
going anything close that's the South
Romana Italy yeah it's all Italy brother
there's nothing the states for me and by
the way there if know why I can't get a
white truffle in the stage no sorry
that's a chin google this that's a door
best place to find black truffles all
right man listen black truffles are good
I like black truffles yeah I be prefer
white yeah yeah it's crazy how expensive
they are yeah I think just cuz the show
you know what that's like the French
border you know why they're so expensive
because they're not natural the mom has
to have c-sections so it's a big process
to get one those pop sure so with the
white truffle
now black truffles you have to dig like
that too um yeah it's like beluga caviar
there's caviar and then there's beluga
caviar very different 15 best place for
truffles in Santa Monica it's everywhere
yeah but that's just food black truffle
- yes service abroad truffles where they
grown is the question why truffles of
crazy I have I had them there what's
that have I had a lady there not giving
those away there well black truffles 30
to $75 bro they're kind of giving them
away one mushroom yeah but the others
worth 10 grand yeah yeah is early white
and black pretty much brother there's no
other truffle you got nice mushrooms out
there but when you start talking about
this special truffle is considered a
mushroom yeah and and if you have the
money if anybody has the money or you
want to take your girl somewhere and
want to spend the money you go to the
wine country you go to Bordeaux you go
to you go to bone you go to those places
you shame Italy you got to pull yak you
go to France and you you during white
truffle season and you eat those wine
restaurants as you go through the
vineyards and it's the best you come to
Vienna pillar that's for that'ss and
then [ __ ] stay at the shores Hotel
get balls deep in your girlfriend after
even white truffle in Venice say again
you could do that you do that instead of
but there's something about France you
know wine come you should start a
truffle hunting team or a couple trial
calendars yeah I'll put you on a leash
you walk around your [ __ ] hands nice
my nose isn't that good I don't use dogs
you know what else could we use you
gotta use pigs or dogs and a spell use a
German Shorthaired you can't just use
any old about a pot-bellied pig I don't
know a bunch of pot bellies it's a good
question we can manage first of all they
gotta have the taste for it that's an
interesting question well then you gotta
feed them so they gotta have a taste see
if they gotta give him a shark blood
once they up human blood you got to take
him down yeah
see if they have see if we look God wait
that was only $2,500 for that that's a
black one yeah the black ones 2500 for 2
and 3/4 pound see pot-bellied pig
truffles that's what we need we need
like ten of them which we command you
need yeah when you get a big big it's
real tough look at that though they got
pigs [ __ ] yes oh look how cute they are
that's what we want a team of there's
like those things little pigs I love a
pig I like you know what I kiss the pig
on the nose and there's one at the grow
those have one at the growth their noses
are not that salt no they're not their
noses it feels like sharks get their
news noses are used to route I know but
they run but this not a route this one
this one's so privileged
it hasn't routed anything there there's
a guy there's a guy looking we know what
that's what I expect the truffle honey
to look like yeah so do I sort of white
with a jacket like hey hey most
expensive truffle in the world Google at
chin how big was that [ __ ] trap a
truffle probably now let me ask em let's
say you were Scrooge McDuck rich you
have two billion dollars would you buy a
truffle the size of an apple and would
you eat it like it
so you can't can you do that oh you
can't do it that way so I it won't taste
the way it doesn't taste good shape
you got to shave it you know I was in a
restaurant and my friend the guy liked
the hangover he was one of the families
who farm truffles he was in famillies
and he gave me one the size of a peach
and I came back with this ones that I
really got a week those a million
dollars yeah yeah it's crazy dude it's
clear as it is in his hand right there
yeah that's a giant truffle that's the
world record that's a four pound truffle
so I take a bite out of that like a big
old peach it's not gonna taste good no
you need it you need to shave it on it's
a very specific taste
I can't believe momma had water I can't
believe you never had a white truffle I
I want to take you there tonight we
should go to Vienna to where we're awful
at we can go there and get the white
corn ravioli with the white drive I'm
gonna do it mouth is watering uh-oh well
you were there last night doing it too
though
yeah but I never get tired of it I mean
it's white truffle season do you want to
go tonight if you say white truffle
season one more time on a real fast
white truffle season I mean come on look
at that look at that truffle it's so
weird how weird the demand form I know
that looks like a piece of cauliflower
only grow is certain they only mature
like that you can only find that so
exists a super rare yes and there's six
feet on the [ __ ] ground look at that
look at that we're done on the moon Rose
it's a it's fungus it's a giant piece of
fuzz the most expensive mushroom in the
world besides the truffle i well i
chanterelles are always pretty expensive
but they're not you know they're far as
much see I love a nice mushroom you know
what as a kid my my step mom would buy
canned mushrooms that come in that we
have water and I'll just eat those all
the time I smelled like [ __ ] yeah I just
eat those non-stop
yeah now think about a lot of metal in
those a lot of metal nothing more
poisonous than the wrong mushroom of
course nothing nothing more poisonous
you die you die quick expensive fungus
in the world click up there truffles the
most expensive food in the world but
there's the top 10 most expensive where
European white truffle let me see the
top most splinter food in the world
let's go through how much
these brightest right number ten have
you ever had a maitake mata suka
mushroom [ __ ] yeah okay $1,000 [ __ ] girl
man laughs never had a Western Hotel
bagel covered in gold
[ __ ] yeah I held in line with the goal
be like I really have what a bore I've
done that yeah [ __ ] off chuckles I've
done that in I've done that
more than at the Western and Eric [ __ ]
off okay he's gonna break the zillion
dollar lobster I know all about it
a thousand dollars yeah yeah you haven't
done it what I have I have eaten the
beluga caviar so yes the answer is yes
now steaks Wagyu Arriba from Snake River
farms which is the best [ __ ] Wagyu
steak you've ever had yeah oh and by the
way been to Japan and eaten Kobe beef
the real Kobe beef where they massage
the [ __ ] cows with beer and it melts
in your mouth it's so cruel to the
[ __ ] cow I don't even think they let
him touch the ground and now that I know
that I probably wouldn't do it all right
he's going to jail so so far we're
people are out of water uh you ever had
that curry with lobster Bombay
brassieres nah I haven't done scroll
down yes for 200 for a piece of pizza
yeah cuz they put what did I do they put
cold pop it all with 24 karat gold
plates I'm not eating those gold flakes
bro what a bore keep going black
watermelon oh wow six goddamn Japan
guarantee it's from Japan I told you oh
god you're in Japan they do these weird
things so in Japan it's a hybrid yeah so
in Japan they obsess over overrun oh
it's only grown in the island of
Hokkaido yeah in Japan
[ __ ] I do how kind of so-so in Japan do
it neat well as ever growing just one
melon to perfection where it's the
sweetest [ __ ] can elaborate and I'll
sell it to you for 24 [ __ ] with channel
oh I love me some watermelon though look
at these here than balance 22 22 grand
for those melons yeah bro that better
come with the hottest chick in the world
yeah how about not of the hottest chicks
in the world with a witty yacht and
everybody's been tested keep scrolling
down
caviar I don't [ __ ] with you like
caviar
if it's the right caviar yes way to saw
I hate how salty stuff what's that I
hate salty stuff yeah well I hated
sardines but that sardine that we had at
you guys who still was nice yeah
if you did if you do if you do beluga
caviar the right way like with Fabrizio
when he goes to Petra Ocean here and
he'll go there and spend you know some
crazy amount of money but he's obsessed
with caviar when you eat it that way
with the Buddhist what do you put on it
it comes with Bellinis it comes with
bleed or not it's a Bellini my egg
whites little baby pancakes it'll come
with some creme fraiche it comes with
like a little horse or breakfast it's
it's just a delicacy it's an item with
caviar I love it sometimes me and chin
had a we ate sushi in Australia you like
the weird [ __ ] I like the worse stuff
yeah yeah well no you like the are you
like the nose about here does OB beef
yes Kobe beef oh man I'll come back I
keep going there's a truffle 160 grand
most expensive food in the world yeah
white Alba Alba bro we need to start a
truffle business mm-hmm called the
truffle shuffle it's so expensive they
sell the oil boys and girls they sell
the oil truffle shuffle productions
truffle shuffle productions truffle
shuffle you know trouble shuffle yes
Brian brain bins we sell white truffles
no only white truffles yeah only white
and for $600 I can't believe I was in
foot lake but really I can do with white
truffles that put it on pasta no you put
it on meat well you put it on me with a
sauce with the truffle with a white
truffle sauce too did they make it sauce
either why trouble excuse me sir
cheese with some cheese and white
truffle if you're dying off the salad
didn't you you put that on there you put
that on the mean on the stick
why on that tomahawk steak they bring
out it sure it is but I don't care
because I feel like we've earned it for
the you know I don't spend like for the
300th episode I feel like we've heard
some white troll thank you what do I
spend money on nothing I don't even like
dress like like but I spend money on
food food and wine you throwing money
staying out food wine and I have a prude
of wine that's all yeah
really the only thing that's been my as
clothes yeah yeah a few cars yeah you're
you're you're amazing like Tiger yeah
I'm like a rapper you're like Tiger yeah
yeah it's all good
I love white truffle apparently I do I'm
so proud I have a white truffle with
cheese on dude how unusually educated on
my worldly views through how if you
you've dropped the ball dropped the ball
but now we're talking about if we ever
had I feel have I never had it
oh yeah black I always have to have you
come do it just even for an hour to the
event oh so we can do the white corn
ravioli and then like a steak with the
WIPO son you lose your mind yeah yeah
yeah we will you'll lose your mind they
bring those black drops on the table I'm
gonna bust no no you know those black
truffles away if it's it's not stupid
it's not I mean I'm pissed that for
burritos in [ __ ] Saint Barts but
we'll get hooked up yeah I'm fascinated
by truffles now we should take our team
right here hmm
we should take our team right here 300
APIs or a single TMJ would like with a
lousy bottle of wine I feel like doing
that you don't think chin deserves it
I think it'd be a great idea and I
should call him a whiff and we'll bring
my whiff I'll get a babysitter and we'll
rock and roll like that sounds like a
plan all right what you think oh yeah oh
you'd be up at 4:00 in the morning but
I'm down I think it's important to the
board I think it's important we steal
their stash of white truffle you don't
lose your [ __ ] mind is there a black
market for white truffles I bet that
there is yeah there's a via like you
know these things are people would steal
those you have to you keep the unlock
monkey 100% where do you store them room
to have your item room temperature I
don't know I think it might be a oh I
knew there was a darkness
Chinese knockoff [ __ ] Chinese agent
meatball sabotage inside the high-stakes
pursuit of course there's fakies they
were doing this with wine tail really I
like high level one to do it with
Rolexes they do
Easy's anything that's high level or
like hard to get people are doing
Chinese does he thank a t-shirts they
arrived this and after the box they
arrived in is pried open each piece of
white travel is carefully unloaded
analyzed for flaws then they're like
dynatrap tin paper towels and placed on
a scale to ensure the total weight
matches the amount of Italian Erie
purchase I'm not trying tell the vendor
everybody but you know you when you get
the vendors so Fabrizio gets from a
family that he's known for ever from
Italy welcome to the restaurant from
Italy and eat at the restaurant and
present their mushrooms it's the Italian
restaurants you go to they know those
families and those families have had
those plots of land and their family for
generations
this is my thing why is it only in Italy
and France that you can get these
troubles is why they grow I can't we do
it here it's only where they grow
apparently they don't grow there they're
very delicate and they only grow in very
specific places so it's like when you go
to beer it's in the South of France on
the border of Spain they are they had
that wild boar prosciutto that it's
called it's called the miracle is me
dude no it's hello it gave me no no it's
called pata Negra and it is [ __ ] pata
Negra pata Negra and dude it is it's the
same kind of thing it's the best it's so
good that they sell it by the [ __ ]
ounce and it's expensive yeah you get a
certificate when you order it in a
restaurant here you they come with a
certificate to prove that it's actually
The Blackout they eat they eat chestnuts
they eat
chestnuts warthogs eat chestnuts they
eat chestnut so they're meat the meat
has the crazies and then the way they
they cure it this [ __ ] goes back man
this [ __ ] goes [ __ ] back for you for
honey to hundreds of years man these are
yes the way you cure the meat don't do
that [ __ ] at home okay and get your
Bologna and get the funk out of line
face hey what it merit if you just gave
the Warthog Nutella because you tella is
not chestnuts
I know now I will say this I've heard
that they've given hogs Parmesan cheese
I love dude Parmesan cheese I mean no
this is good I got a good
you can keep your [ __ ] I got all
cheese I got a nice cheese I got a
cheese when you got it what's our
favorite nice this is no milk or aw
she's milk that they sell it the whole
food sheep milk please trust me when I
please I'm getting hungry man I got an
advert I'm like [ __ ] that might work I'm
starving yeah
go find your [ __ ] white truffle I
want one too well you know and also when
you eat the meat when we go and have a
steak at when I take you guys for the
steak this is not a cow that comes from
just any old farm he's been fed mr.
beech is a maniac this [ __ ] yes
yes he goes to the farm he's like wait a
minute
how are you feeding these cows well I
want like Italy then he slaps us to
pieces he's a mess
he's a [ __ ] madman what you know it
goes back to anybody who's obsessed with
quality anybody was obsessed with our
materials here this way that you'd be
exactly this way this [ __ ] will
and also the the the the purest he is
there's a restaurant it's making noise
and stuff by the way Tuesday night
completely packed this [ __ ] guy is
he'll go to a restaurant they'll talk
it's a big thing and he can he'll talk
about like the difference in hype and
when it's really good food and he'll be
like happens all the time he's sexy but
he's such an [ __ ] he's breeches all
Halon oh he's such a hater the
competitor he's anything he's a nut and
he'll be like this hey like come on it's
great food and he'll go I couldn't and
I'm just you know for me everybody has a
chance it's great but I couldn't put the
food to my mouth I couldn't even the
minute I report it is like he's that
like I immediately my mouth like it had
a mind of its own its spit it spit
everywhere I couldn't I couldn't even
eat it like he's that much of an [ __ ]
they're killing it sushi restaurants
don't [ __ ] tell him to eat at I
torture him with scopa because he knows
I got a scope on we love you haven't
been there forever I do I see our boy
every table every morning a boxing movie
I've talked him all time so he left
today remember we talked about on the
show where he was going to the dr right
to deliver that they raised a bunch of
money shots fired kid army they raised a
bunch of money so he goes today
thanks guys forgiven but I see them all
the time dude you're never and I'm like
I just I don't live over there in my
living palace we got it we got it we got
to go we got to go we got to circle more
um because that's another go to
obviously but go but if I bring that
[ __ ] up to February where I'll go I'm
thinking about going to dinner scope was
not a chain no it's just
and yeah competitor yeah but also Scopus
I said Todd Feldman there he got done
with the I don't know Emmy party or
something like that
he was wears like a cool hangover
there's now a lot of people I said go to
the old scope a room they just opened up
on an old what he caught uh uh bar no
not a bar speaking the speakeasy yes I
said its membership only there's maybe
about six people in there it's some of
the best liquor in the world it's
vintage it's old the whole vibe they
take it which keeps on the fifth it's so
cool yeah Japanese whiskeys everything J
super in the whiskey's I'm into whiskey
now all you love your brother cuz he got
mom to come he got hippie can't stuff
I'm a Campari you like your Campari I
like my extra in the a hill Jim tequilas
and now I'm into Japanese whiskeys now
I'm a gentleman Amistad gentleman I just
I've slowed down but I was going through
almost two bottles kanpai oh wait you
were yeah you know me when I like
somebody gonna addicted to how about the
back that you posted Campari all you do
is post like your drink it well you
weren't getting paid for anything and
you just get all this [ __ ] you're like
[ __ ] [ __ ] hey Dad bro trying to [ __ ]
me a guy who doesn't drink ever it's
gonna start posting Campari [ __ ] chill
Mike Jesus I'm getting paid I love it if
I'm getting paid back it does that but
what's the other one after all or ever
all is it's a light red it's some
[ __ ] like the bitterness comparing
Campari you gotta go alright special now
depend redid it no me and Jim after Koz
went to the bar next year on the bar
next or the table scam i word it there
you look like a [ __ ] if they put in the
wrong container because it looks like
you're a flu free drink sure I'm a
gentleman
you gotta put in gentlemen Scott cuz he
put it remote you won't put him umbrella
and make me look like an ass you just
say a certain did I ask for dick suck
what they deserve no a Campari because
don't you know old Campari's that is a
gentleman's drink
if you drink Campari your life whatever
hat you want suits boots you smell of
vintage cigars it's nice I like that
it's had may I ask you but you put up a
[ __ ] fruit in my Campari bro
you trying to [ __ ] me yeah yeah trying
to bang me trying to give up signal
umbrella yeah everyone knows that I'm
Bellamy come on by no don't put on
brother you have to put a nice gentleman
cotta so I don't know you had a head
I've sent abstinence no I didn't say
abstinence I said absinthe absinthe I
sure don't see absinthe was illegal in
this country is that the word
hallucinogens in it now absinthe is a
beauty and you put it on a sugar cube
right different ways once you want you
to educate us on some absinthe but you
can't get the real cherry hard minded
you can get it but you gotta go we don't
like truffle an absence oh yeah you need
you need Bravo what's gonna happen we're
gonna eat a bunch of white truffles down
some athletes yeah absolutely
I'm gonna have to crazy with you game
saying don't say boys Royce abstinence
is when you you know when you don't yeah
so it's absence absence you have a AB
you don't live in soon it's the
forbidden drink absolute forbid dress if
you see me drinking absinthe and you
walk in you go huh right and I go
nothing nothing to see here
no nothing here you walk into a bar in
Venice or Abbot Kinney and you see Brian
I drinking absinthe you clutch your
chest cuz we're up to nine you open your
your peach cuz we're gonna do some weird
[ __ ] oh if we're drinking absinthe there
it can turn you gay if we ever end up
make it out if we are if we ever held
only get other bro calls for mm no but
we ever you know I would never I would
never dare hey you try saying that word
and not having a list no if I ever see
us drinking absinthe Lisp try it chin
it's made from wormwood to other herbs
look a little bit of list made if you
have a list it's made
list yours is bad by the way by the way
and mg I have to warn you when I start
talking about wine and I start I start
feeding you that food there's a very
good chance you get confused and you're
like bro why am i draw I was just here
say the same thing I'm a drawing brides
are some about wine and white truffles
yeah yeah well I'm holding court and
ordering for that you pay for those two
daddy get his dick sucked
yeah buddy okay how was going to say
what are you talking about what are you
gonna say that's why I draw the line
please
wait what so but absolutes made of
wormwood and other herbs originally used
as a bitter de Geste teeth well you know
what that means
dee jest teeth to help you digest your
food no she absinthe
go back scroll up absinthe can be
difficult to procure high-quality up
Seth is made by using more moon and
other herbs during the distillation
process although it is not uncommon for
commercial examples of absinthe to be
made by merely soaking an herbal mixture
and alcohol I won't have that I want the
real gin can we were the real thing on
there how do we know whether we trust it
we got to go first you got to go to we
gotta go to scope and in fact I bet you
I problem they have it I promise you I
don't think rhombus illegal deserves the
real ones illegal to serve we got back
we got back room channels bro I don't
think so man I guarantee Pablo has some
look where can i buy the real absence I
promise you I've since original it's a
deep green it's not cheap well it's a
gift set of three super sceptile hippo
eyes Oh top right chin yeah we'll get
down reviews down down down yeah right
there right there right a dollars pounds
that's not real damn I guarantee
someone's innocence a link that it I
mean Indians like I sent it to did I
include you on this
yeah even getting some strong Deanna's
from do me guys try to jack it out for
their feet and [ __ ] but then late levity
and DMS some guy goes so now he goes bro
you hooked me up with MJ I will suck
your dick and I put well I never had so
much but well probably
just shot your chances makes if you're
willing to suck my dick can't give you
an MJ boy but Jocelyn get hooked me up
with MJ alright Pangea is a random guy
on I got another one the guy goes bro I
will wash your car for a year if you
give me MJ's number it's not bad it's
not bad I mean now we can start to gave
them yeah that's a pretty good deal I
get weird offers man all the time yeah
yeah I guess trying Jack now for the
feet though I don't know what it is I
don't know some people are in there god
this guy the 50 year old I get no sexual
no you're going to now guys love feet
will creepy guys well not all creepy
guys it's a weird thing I won put on my
Instagram it's like a yoga photo and the
guys like I love your arches he's like I
want to see them around my Wow who's
gonna say arches around dick well I
don't know I'm just trying to put two
and two together
arches well that's not so weird I'm I'm
with that guy largest but the arches of
your feet
yeah I always think of arch like when
you're at your back your ass and your
it's all good yeah I'm with that but the
feet is weird like it's like a vaccine
could you know whenever you're watching
porno sometimes it's just like I'll say
care I'm a huge fan of but dr. K and
she'll be there like jacking a dude off
with her feet yeah she's got if you have
a little feet like I've dated girls that
have little feet my wife could ski but
but it's all good no game times was that
big understanding um and she's gonna
kill me when she hears this but she's
got some [ __ ] [ __ ] some flat
presenting guts just a plasters on it
she does not know yeah I know that right
away cuts right through the water swims
you know she wears those new balances
but those extra wide gray ones when we
go snorkeling feels like not good
Michael just don't put them together
like that cuz you'll be shark bait you
look like ya
anyway but um we're talking again jacked
off by your feet
most girls have small feet dog likes I
like short toes small feet wide wide
cute little argent roll yeah sure like
hi yeah if you like short water likewise
short toes hair on the cows is on the
bottom I like nails that come over and
scrape the ground
I like that here goes weirdest Kim
you've gotten MJ cuz like um guys I mean
video of him jacking off
you have a piece do you have a date on
them usually it got that weird angle
Tori's like all low and like right next
to it that's tough to tell yeah he's a
master with the angles and lighting it's
not a weird sexual thing people want you
to watch them and people are breaking
your house and jerk off in your closet
what I do
well I'd I've done some yeah [ __ ]
stuff as I'm jacking off but I've had
some weird stuff man
how about my friend who's like this I
damn it what I don't know I'm like what
I might've banged a [ __ ] well what do
you mean you might have banged a trained
dancer feet were just gigantic I'm like
well alright how tall is she about six
four well that's in a shoe bro at size
13 I gotta be like listen I'll pay your
cab fare but this is not gonna work out
Oh disgusting oh I'm not fan of bugs
either I heard they're really
comfortable and they are pretty cool Tom
Brady wears them whatever I tried to
wear this vibrant this fiber I finally
rolling swears by my I wore the forever
China's up full yeah they will they will
they will mock down boners and dry up
vaginas but they also will [ __ ] your if
you're not they do right you'll [ __ ]
your feet off sure do if you're not used
to them you gotta be a headstone you got
to work up to yeah yeah yeah like what
Walker in them but if you just jump and
run Biff and those who get [ __ ] I can't
shoot I'll get my keys how's that sound
yeah is 2007 along with Nike barefoot
running is all good but yeah no thanks
speaking of weird things Aubrey mark is
hopefully I can say this he sent me a
thing goes got he said me and wrote me
the thing you
group text message he goes well things
getting weird and some random dude got a
picture of his fiance Whitney who's
obviously gorgeous best ass in the world
made by NASA it's ridiculous yeah she
was artificially created in a lab price
Batman anyways some random dude got a
tattoo of her on his arm that's sounds
all well you gotta put a restraining
order now that's so weird
oh [ __ ] that's very straight that's very
disconcerning they just work
no he's play stalking her yeah that's
creepy alright you stay or she's really
hot he's got a cool tattoo of a girl
there guys a good girl it's just her
head not like I could understand if you
got a picture for bending over and
bikini like that makes sense you're
weird but you're the bro bro it's
artistic like is it look like real those
like soul and girls you know it looks
like Whitney if she had touch of the
death and also if it's your head that's
always like what does that joke with a
serial killer you know so your killers
you know he's a serial killer when he
complements unit egos you have a really
nice head excuse me yeah great looking
have you had any uh like crazy stuff MJ
stalkers or anything did you go to now
that you're part of this show figuring
Hamra for god sake with boots it's good
for ratings
um I've gotten some weird ones I haven't
gone through him although yet I have a
lot of requests crazy cuz your Instagram
was private for a while I did private
for a little bit cuz I had some weirdo
like someone showed up in my yoga studio
and it was super weird because I saw him
like four different times when I was
going to my yoga studio so I'm like I
don't want to like release stuff about
like what I'm doing now but then when I
got the shows like our elves make it
public again so yeah I do you say like
low-key about like my whereabouts my
town oh yeah yeah I feel like girls get
more like weird stuff than guys do I
mean this you're a public figure I got
like I get weird stuff funny though like
no if God wants to jam out for this feat
okay you're never gonna Jack me off with
you if you're not gonna hold me down
Jack man through your feet nice you're
Cain Velasquez I'm with
please don't please don't
but if you have to I get it but like you
you know if a big man wants to know do
some stuff it's it's tricky and scary
it's weirder than the guys with
girlfriends they're hitting me up like I
look at their page and it's like two
days ago he posted the girlfriend yeah
that is weird cuff tear why - I'm
believing MJ you mean you get guys who
have girlfriends hitting on us why look
what a lot of guys would - that I'm
outraged nothing too crazy though huh
and you don't get anything being I
figured maybe get like the girls with
daddy issues - like I want to be
won't you be yeah do sometimes I guess
you probably don't really eat mine you
don't really check your da I'm not yeah
like we just I can't believe I'm talked
about this before but so the comments on
our YouTube page you know ever YouTube
page yeah yeah so the comments on
YouTube page were disabled for a while
we had nothing do with that we someone
else runs our YouTube page like chin
uploads it and then we have a company
that is in charge of running that page
coming up making other and so the
comments were disabled i I've never even
seen our YouTube page right you haven't
I don't read comics you only I don't
give a [ __ ] I guess this big deal and I
didn't notice in J and Jimmy is where
they go hey comments are disabled we
gotta figure out because people whether
it's hate good they'd like the comments
can hurt you yeah ratings on it it's
sparse discussion I guess everything
well it so it's a place for hate to but
I don't I don't read it's I don't care
yeah all I care about is the views
that's cuz we make money off that all I
care about so how many people see it to
get our product out there's always gonna
be yeah I don't give a [ __ ] but now
they're back on for the most part my
might when I do read my Dan is they're
always so positive DMS are different DM
is going to be positive
yeah the actual comments well it depends
yeah yeah I felt a sense of you're like
I like read like yeah you sometimes
people I count as a [ __ ] this area
you're probably you know you're kind of
right sometimes you know what I mean
calzone overall blowhard [ __ ]
mmm he's a braggart meat sometimes
you're you know sir you probably
sometimes I 100 percent cream it just
I'm not
I happy with myself that's what I was
gonna kick out of like like if I do
rogue and I get a bunch of stuff like
well yeah probably in that case I was I
was talking too much or I was bragging
yeah yeah yeah on that day I just don't
have any friends that would leave a
negative comment on another person
social media pay have to do that yeah
it's very positive yes happy yes I left
so I'd actually hate yeah I I have no
person in my social circle that would
ever do the only time I ever did that
was Maureen Dowd who was a columnist for
The New York Times and she was always so
critical and she's just one of those
gals who never really participated in
anything she never competed she just was
the girl and the in the stands always
looking down at those of us sweating and
judging nice and judging it was narky
snarky comments with snarky and she did
it too you know different politicians
and presidents and and she would always
do it to Bush or whoever and I was
always like you're not being you reached
out to her on this I I know on her I
wrote a comment to her I said I wrote
her a thing and I said you know Reno I
said you know worrying you you should
come join the fray sometime you might be
less critical but it's very easy to
response no I don't know I never yeah
probably not but I tried to be fair and
I wasn't I wasn't me and I just said you
tend to you have a little flaw and that
is that you you're you're really witty
but you do it standing up in the stands
looking down at those in the game and in
the fight and is he really hard that
that never bothers me like if whatever
song goes oh job you [ __ ] suck your
fights suck if I see so that never
bothers me because you're just a sheep
in the crowd that does it now if it was
from felt like if Cain Velasquez or
Conor McGregor or you know fade or
someone who my peers were okay you
[ __ ] suck like I I got addressed this
yeah but Sony's never walked the walk it
doesn't I mean I think some be up
[ __ ] yeah
am i literally a sheep should have wrote
that and we've had some constructive
comments like I've had comments that
were constructive like criticisms that
were that made sense that I was like
yeah you know like something like listen
more don't interrupt your guests or
whatever my Shero yeah
you're right there's a big difference
between constructive in their system
just being a skater yeah it's like kind
of like the difference between like you
know people are super positive all the
time like they're everything's positive
that's good it's good to be positive
it's also important to be critical and
to be a critical thinker if you know
what you're talking about
if you know what you're talking about if
you know you're talking about that's
right that's exactly right
but this day and age we live in everyone
has a voice thinks their opinion matters
well get in bed and then sometimes you
don't have as sophisticated an eye or
your you're seeing things so I watch the
when I watch The Donald Cerrone Robbie
Lawler fight I thought Donald won that
hands down oh no and then you were like
you know you were like it was I'm super
biased for me I loved but you were like
no it was a very close fight yeah no he
got out I could have gone on and I gave
it to Robbie yeah but I like this yeah
but you know one got robbed right and
Donald didn't think he got robbed no
don't but for me I was watching it and
I'm you know again it might have been
the built-in bias I had for Donald but
for me I was like what thought what you
know no no no just some Kermit said can
we take a break real quick yeah yeah
therapy [ __ ] to Nestor you share too
good all right oh great and Brian you
eatin starburst you eat a million
starburst a day Brian did you see what I
posted that arbic gentleman now I'm
getting [ __ ] on my Instagram because
some guy posted trying to sing the
skylar astin song and he's in Dubai yeah
and so I assumed he was Arabic but I
guess he's not people to give me [ __ ]
now cuz I guess he's some from somewhere
else oh he looks like me better looking
better skin for sure wait clear skin
he's not singing my don't singing my
theme song
he's from the least but not Arabic they
go you're just gonna assume oh yeah we
are and I'm gonna assume and I'm gonna
tell you that he's in Dubai bond and
he's in the United Arab Emirates let me
tell you what that was saying he's 100
in Arabic um so I put voice of an angel
and they go you're assuming to buy
anything to buy he's Jack he would be
he's jacked me jacked well no
hey hey white truffle
boy calm down Jesus very Arabic Arabic
or from Barnsley let me see or from what
Barnsley fellow northerner he might be
British of Arabic descent alright well
it goes ah this is some dude put this
you know these are [ __ ] haters lol
slight air B job
pretty sure he's from an Indian
background like myself how I could be I
see why you assume Eric because of his
profile from Dubai he can't sing though
he might be Indian or a big Indian
presence so I shouldn't assumed Arabic
but I thought Arabic you be Pakistani
Indian so I I should have put every
angel I think everything though
I like Arabic angel he sings like an
Arab angel like an Arabic name became an
Arabic angel mm-hmm
Jenni uh before we jump in current
events anything going on with your
dating life yes said another date no
there's nothing we did talk about
hanging out again though we had set the
date nothing on the books not which
wants to go singing again just loves to
sing
let you guys thing she loves it when
when you sing yeah yeah yeah you should
do a private concert for it yeah yeah um
do you guys text every day though not
every day you know what you're too
cryptic with all the answers
I'm not did you kill her chin did you
kill her and freezer a head in your
refrigerator Wow no no one text
remaining I still haven't answered from
her yeah you play hard to get I'm just
trying to do my thing chin your forehead
there's no play there's no games
give it time you know who don't play
games these guys we don't play games we
cut to the right case through it if I
couldn't wait this long I'll play the
game yeah I'm you're playing right
played hard you get with her mmm yeah
probably work that bothers me
me too did you ask your advisor if you
do this cuz my advisor me and Brian or
no I just asking we've made it this far
bro you're in the Temple of Doom you
want [ __ ] the two guys with the torch
thing all the advice you guys gave me
was itwas met well wait didn't work out
that way oh dear J is [ __ ] bro you go
on one date now you're the data expert I
don't know a lot of people that message
me they give me tips like rope good tips
and they're always like don't listen to
Brendan O'Brien
they haven't dated like nowadays right
even like you day yeah you're sort of
brand new alright never mind but that's
what I got I got tons of messages of
people saying like that's not how the
dating game works right now and they're
specially not in there mumble then
they're saying play hard-to-get and
these are all people who are single cuz
I've done tinder and grind they are all
with girls now a lot of them that
they're girls are fiance's on tinder and
Bumble yeah you might wanna listen yeah
and they're saying play this game oh no
this one's more like I don't know I
don't know what I want to say yet that's
why do you want a serious girlfriend not
right now alright then alright well
unless unless I guess we can wasted our
complete dunno actually know hey you
never know what's gonna happen with this
one I wouldn't have met her without you
guys I like to see me though I like her
I want you working out alright I want
you looking your best you're 40 let's
step the [ __ ] game up tone we're on
our 300th episode and I'm being dead
serious
if I have no back sharing you haven't
worked out I want you I want you tight I
want you tight I don't want yours Jason
I do I'm just talking about you taking
it out more frequently I don't mean
tight I want ya I don't know what's
going on there for tight [ __ ] what you
do with your body I do I just want you
taking this girl out more not playing
hard to get I want you're working out
and I want you I want you to piledrive
alright mining let's go to the parts of
current events this one's a big deal
right now Eminem this know so the BT
Awards were yesterday right I believe
they were yesterday I said some rhymes
I'm can spit some rhymes on Trump yeah
and this is all freestyle not pretty
wrote play this for Brian yeah he
thought so according to this it's
freestyle before the storm right here
I went on translate there wait how was I
gonna start this huh you tell forgot oh
yeah that's an awfully hot coffee pot
should I drop it on Donald Trump
probably not but that's all I got till I
come up with a solid got a plan and now
I got a hatchet like a damn Apache would
at I'm a hawk I'm a walk inside a mosque
on Ramadan and say a prayer that every
time talks she gets a motley ah I'm a
stop but we better give Obama props cuz
what we got in office now is a kamikaze
that'll probably cause a nuclear
holocaust
and while the drama pops and he waits
for [ __ ] to quiet down he'll just gas
his plane up and fly around to the
bombing stops intensity's heightened
tensions are rising Trump when it comes
to giving a [ __ ] you're stingy as I am
except when it comes to having the balls
to go against me you hide him cuz you
don't got the nuts like an empty asylum
racism's the only thing he's fantastic
for cuz that's how he gets his rocks off
and he's orange ya sick Ted that's why
he wants us to disband cuz he cannot
withstand the fact we're not afraid of
Trump walking on eggshells I came to
stop that's why he keeps screaming
draining the swamp cuz he's in quicksand
it's like we take a step forwards than
backwards but this is his form of
distraction plus he gets an enormous
reaction when he attacks the NFL so we
focus on that and instead of talking
Puerto Rico a gun reform for Nevada
all these horrible tragedies and he's
bored and would rather cause a Twitter
storm with the Packers in their
brilliant
he wants to lower our taxes the news
gonna pay for sex trafficking trips back
and forth with his fam did was golf
resort to this mansions same [ __ ] that
he tormented Hillary for and he
slandered then does it more from his
endorsement abandon support for the
Klansmen tiki torches in hang for the
soldier that's blacking comes home from
Iraq and it's still told to go back to
Africa for can a dagger in this racist
94 year old grandpa who keeps ignoring
our past historical deplorable factors
now if you're a black athlete you're a
spoiled little brat for trying to use
your platform of your stature to try to
give those a voice you don't have one he
says you're spitting in the face of vets
who fought for us you bastards unless
your appeal W who's tortured and patted
cuz to him your seals cuz he don't like
his war heroes caption that's not
disrespecting the military that this is
for Colin Paul up a fist and keep that
[ __ ] bald like Donald the [ __ ] he's
gonna get rid of our immigrants he's
gonna build that banging up taller miss
well if he does build it
I hope it's rock solid with bricks cuz
like him and politics I'm using all of
his tricks because I'm throwing that
decent [ __ ] against the wall till it's
fixed in any fan of mine who's a
supporter of his I'm drawing in the
sander line you either for or against
and if you can't decide who you like
more in your split on who you should
stand beside I'll do it for you with
this the rest of America stand up we
love our military and we love our
country
but we hey well I wish his entourage
would have done something though they're
just like yeah I need some reaction
that's brilliant though yeah man that's
America right there the voice in your
it's exercising your First Amendment
what do you believe it he does it in a
pretty creative way that's what I that's
what I appreciate it's so good that's
some legit points though it's so
creative too man
this whole and it felt controversy this
it's it's it's it's America its debate
its debate its debate it's it's what we
have to contend with have you seen the
stuff going on with Jerry Jones the
Dallas Cowboys it's getting pretty
tricky now what he's doing is he's
demanding that his players hold hands
certain way look a certain way do
something a certain way during the
national anthem and if they don't he's
gonna bench him what I heard is all the
black players are gonna not do it take
your name not gonna strike you something
yeah do something you get if all the
african-american players decide to 75%
of above the league is african-american
I think oh if we good players that can
except for they have a lot of fun
quarters a lot of time'n if they chose
to strike no they have all the power
yeah no they have a little pad there's
no NFL without african-american there's
no sports in America without
african-american yeah dude up the UFC we
have a lot of you know there's some
diversity but you have the USC but then
there's no I mean type hockey yeah but
forget baseball forget MBA think the NFL
I think that the the issue becomes I was
talking to a bunch of guys and they were
talking about that's all sports fans and
I said who are the guy reminded them
they're guys who are construction guys
and they're doing some work in my house
oh yeah and they're not bad guys and
they're are Mexican guys there and they
were they were they're they're fair
amount of guys and they were kind of
debating about this you know topic and I
reminded them which time I felt the best
some guys were veterans who didn't want
to kneel and then they got pressured in
the kneeling and it was all this stuff
and it's a very contentious issue and
it's and it's fine to be it's actually
fine to be conflicted by it it's also
fine to be offended by it it's also but
remember I think that you know kneeling
during the national anthem doesn't
necessarily mean you doesn't necessarily
mean that you're in
tension is disrespect the flag it might
mean that your intention is to bring
attention to an injustice in your
country and that's what we're doing that
that's been lost because otherwise
framing it differently exactly and so I
think that you know that my I always
remind I reminded them and I always
remind people of my favorite Mark Twain
quote which is loyalty to my country
always to my government only when it
deserves it that is American and so you
know with with mm who's not using the
gun or anything else but using his
[ __ ] words in a creative way he has a
right to say you know [ __ ] you and I
don't believe in this and that is what
makes America a very dynamic place the
fact that you have a platform for that
that's so important and again when colin
kaepernick who's kind of being a started
this whole thing um even he said that
this whole thing's been lost in
translation yes yeah because he was just
trying to make a point about there's an
injustice that I that I and the only way
I not to express myself of this platform
is this he was exercising his conscience
does it make mean he's a bad American I
don't think so and play football the
part of part of what's great about the
that he doesn't serve big nerds no he's
not you know a team part of my part of
what I find interesting about the flag
is that it is a symbol of exactly that
is the the fact that you have the
ability to exercise your free will now
you're working for a private company
that gets into very different things
and it seems that and you would know
this better every team has their own
kind of rules then there's the NFL visit
and a film rules it's interesting but
it's an interesting one of the frittatas
one of them not not the owners the UFC
one the other brothers old owners do UFC
but when they all the other brothers
just about the Houston Rockets like 3
billion or something like that and he
went up went on there and the price of
NBA teams has skyrocketed so I'm funny
the inflation for an NBA team and the
NFL's not as much and he goes they asked
him out by an NFL team because he wanted
buy an f15 goes mmm they're just not the
way then I felt going I would not invest
my money and then I felt and I agree
with that right now yeah it's going down
a kind of a weird Road but you know I
don't I'm not offended personally as
somebody who considers all the Patriot
I'm not offended by the fact
certain people kneel during the national
anthem because I think my country is
strong enough to withstand that and I
think that that is almost an expression
of why my country is great because
people are allowed to do that without
being thrown in jail you know but people
can jobs though yeah yeah and that's the
responsibility that you take because
when you make a statement like that it's
gutsy and the reason it's gutsy is
because you could pay a price for it
with your courageous yet Jude yeah all
right this one is Mark Hunt I follow
mark on on Instagram so I saw this
yesterday he went off on Dana White
pretty hard this is like the most I've
seen him go off on do you know what uh
let me read it so mark cut at Dana White
you're a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] why
you spelt [ __ ] wrong but why you
[ __ ] pulled me from the fight you
getting another lawsuit you [ __ ] you
can kiss my ass you bald-headed prick
finger finger finger finger finger
finger finger finger you put that
chicken [ __ ] [ __ ] in get [ __ ]
call him and I'm gonna get to retweet
that cuz you're not using good words
they're not yeah you know I don't think
he's not that creative yeah he's not
known you know first is vocabulary but
he's probably really upset really really
upsetting for you know originally was
slated that he was pulled off because he
said previously in the interview that
he's seen signs of brain trauma major CT
he forgets things he slurring his words
it's hard to get up in the morning and
so they're based off that interview and
I saw Brett Akiyama Okamoto Okamoto put
you know he announced that what do you
think this has anything to do with this
lawsuit he goes no he's fought twice
with a lawsuit but I find it a little
since when did the UFC care about guys
brain health I've seen guys who are
worse off than Mark Hunt fight that's
for sure so I don't know what's going on
and I think there's more to the story I
don't think it's just because he did and
every time out but you know brain health
I mean this is a card in his place to
Sydney Sydney Australia he's gonna
headline so now they have their do a lot
now that ver doomed filling in form
which is very strange I don't know I
don't know the whole story there I wish
I did but I love Mark Hunt and that's a
real shame
and not the best post he's obviously
upset he's probably super emotional very
very upset when you gotta take have a
friend go haha improver you definitely
yeah I'm approved I reread that for you
but that's also why you love mark cut
only twenty thousand well that's also
why you love mark hunt though too
because he you know yeah where does
hardness leave I guess hopefully it
works out for him but I don't know
that's scary if you can't get cleared in
Australia but what's weird is Australia
Athletic Commission cleared them and the
UFC was super weird to come off that's
why I think there's more to the story
that's why I asked Brett I'm like hold
up what about you don't think it's lost
you guys anything do this so I don't
know how and look at what picture he
chooses for the post I thought was
interesting to how so it looks really
rock and roll ish in a nice car I like
just his face those are glass glasses
yeah hmm standard selfie look I don't
know what kind of car that is looks
gonna can't tell it's got custom
interior work flames super Simone I
don't know yeah there might be some dope
right good for him he deserves it what
else you got alright the next one is
after the shooting the Vegas shootings
remember Dan Bilzerian posted that
picture of or the ship snapchat whatever
anyways a the Medal of Honor where that
called him out he's saying that dan
Bilzerian has been giving his wife's the
Medal of Honor winners wife's phone
number out to people and then people are
harassing her I found out that his wife
is actually Bristol Palin Sarah Palin's
daughter and this Medal of Honor winner
is her husband now he's challenging
Gamble's area into a fight dan gave up
the wife that's why he's assuming
because all of a sudden started that's a
big assumption though yeah I don't know
I I'm gonna go I'm gonna go and say the
Medal of Honor when there's not a bad
guy and probably not making stories up
no but he might be have heard that I
mean does he know that he's giving you
just he went made a video and said like
I know you gave this stuff up I mean no
one knows really story in to know that's
but he wants to fight him now he's
challenging to kind of fight an actual
fight man-to-man me me man-to-man enough
games there's no way Dan meets
face-to-face that'd be sick fee to be a
well it's a kind of no-win if you're de
experimental Honor winner which I don't
think you would but no that's awkward
I remember Bilzerian saying before he
wanted to take an MMA fight how dare you
he said that before CM Punk wasn't dan
Bilzerian seen actually with gloves on
helping people yes so he was
okay back with a gun Nene and and the
guy who is the meaning of security or
it's good to [ __ ] with me I don't know
you
yeah and he goes well let me help and
then then he was seen helping people
yeah yeah gloves on he was actually help
no he's definitely helping but the
criticism from that guy marijuana owner
was just that he wouldn't be filming
himself saying that stuff you would you
know be doing the other thing yeah I saw
that the only other problem is that you
don't know where those those massive
machine-gun bullets are coming from and
all that stuff I mean you know he did go
back and help people and I think that's
that's worth something
indeed you know you know I really do I
don't know Dan Bilzerian I doubt they're
gonna fight though giant was actually
good Jen alright so there's more updates
to the Harvey Weinstein stuff so Clinton
Gwyneth Paltrow Hillary Clinton Angelina
Jolie the Obamas they're all they're all
condemning what he did now and then
since then his wife who was gonna back
him up 100% she eventually said she's
gonna leave him now make sense she said
my heart breaks for all the ways I never
suffered you see Lindsay Lohan defendant
that's the other one you never anything
to me he doesn't need backup when that's
like by the way and she's getting
roasted yeah
come on and by the way you know these
people who say well why didn't these
women speak up before and so she you see
Terry Crews Kendall Terry Crews
Schneider
let me see his wife she saw it Oh his
wife oh jeez that's his wife yes his
wife was his wife would you think he was
gonna be a troll yes apart from in three
decades not to the same way let me see
why she's 41 she's very 2007 of two
children
Wow okay
I can no backup no she's face no [ __ ]
she left
why look at how hot she is too by the
way what are you doing a while powerful
man with a hot chick weird yeah also
there's a Terry Crews came out and said
that Jesus yeah Terry Crews was also a
victim of Hollywood see this Terry Crews
said he was out apart I was reading the
shows he was at a party with his wife
this big Hollywood executive goes hey
how you doing gov and grabs his dick
he's in front of the wife yeah and his
wife was like what the [ __ ] but he's
such a powerful guy Terry was like I
didn't say anything like I thought about
the headline Oh Ted Cruz heads up
Hollywood exec yeah it's very Cruz he'll
be your [ __ ] brakes off I don't know
that's weird he just grabbed this dick
and fondled him in front of his wife and
was like have a good day and I guess he
like called the next one was okay I'm
embarrassed by what happened my bat in
tears like I want to say something I'm
scared I won't work again all this other
stuff it was like some high-powered guy
hilarie Burton accuses Rob Schneider he
was a victim of it too oh come on
what's Rob Schneider say he said like a
Power exec came to meet him in a
bathrobe and then asked Rob to crawl
towards him like at their hotel I know
but come on Rob like and that's a little
strange like but why if it happened to
him why is it all right I don't get it
but you're with Terry Crews it wasn't a
big deal because wrong why I don't know
I just feel like guys clearly hey no
you're everyone's the problem you guys
coming yeah that's yeah I think it's
good it's open discussion you're you
talk about how it's good in America
anyone has voice there yeah going on
that big American [ __ ] highway which
I've heard but when guys come out like
now I mean Rob's not a big guy so if the
guy was a big dude I don't know no it
doesn't matter be my fire here it
doesn't matter the guy has so much power
over him yeah that's the problem
can I just see it what are you saying
here oh that's Terry Cruz's thing but I
remember him saying like if this was
before he was really famous that's what
Rob said last year though Terry Crews
shoulda told I gotta go [ __ ] himself
thanked him no he can't you got to read
it but you gotta listen be he go
the guy was such in the high position I
was working a movie for him if I come
out against him I'm not gonna work again
that is so bizarre the guy came up and
just start groping him huh
that's his whole story right there
anyway I was gonna kick his ass right
then thought twice about their peer what
are you doing my wife saw everything we
looked and he's crazy
of course he's just he's crazy he just
grinned just clapped another divided
yeah from his wife yeah you know no I
don't know grab my dick I'd be like hey
man what are you doing like hey this is
the I'm sorry but my hold on this is
different and let me tell you how it's
different and it's very important to
make a distinction here what Harvey want
seemed into these women when they were
in their 20s coming out completely naked
and chasing them around the you know the
room and then threatening them in some
instances with the career suicide don't
embarrass me if you embarrass me I'll
ruin your career and you are you have
your big break and you are sitting there
and you are so vulnerable with this
giant man that is a very different
situation because you're not in a party
your wife isn't there I'm talking about
[ __ ] well but if that is no no no no
no no no nobody's draw a distinction
none will let you can but it's it
bullying's bullying if you're in a power
position well they're smaller
yeah but neat but guess what be
neither's alright I never said it was
alright
I just forgive me if I'm not as outraged
by that or worried about that where I
don't where everybody's coming out this
is a history of doing this to young
girls jerking off on a plant just
grabbing him all kinds of [ __ ] man and
they had no recourse none they had to
just be quiet because they knew if they
said anything this guy would ruin
everything that would be the the thing
is that's what Ted Cruz is saying like
the he was working with this gotten many
projects he was if I say anything I
won't work it's so weird
it's so bizarre to me what are you
[ __ ] doing you come up in a party and
grab his dick and what none of it's good
it's all it's all it's good people are
coming out male or female none of it's
okay
whether you're female or male both of
its [ __ ] up because if you decide
someone's fate whether mu
the TV show many things get away with
sexual harassment
yeah whether you're male or female it's
not cool it's the definition of sexual
harassment if you're in if you're in a
position of power and you use your
position of power to intimidate somebody
into giving you [ __ ] favors you know but
no [ __ ] but play this yeah right this
time it heard it okay
now let me hear it listen to this what's
up
no I mean oh yeah this is really tough
I'm telling you wait did you just pause
let me know
refresh it I'm telling you right get in
here and he just looked so but I mean I
[Music]
[Music]
I'm not doing anything
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nobody Esther was coming I will never do
another thing to you five minutes don't
mean your friendship to me for five
minutes
where's your making a big scene
yeah so that's that's threatening
basically if you ruin your friendship
with me and in your big break you've
been told you coming up there for a
[ __ ] job okay and you're nervous and
it's so hard to make a living in
Hollywood it's so [ __ ] hard for women
you finally get your big break with the
biggest guy in Hollywood and then you
get that and he's naked
it appears Morgan have an interesting
write-up about Hollywood and how you
know a lot of people knew this was going
on and how they're all up in arms now
but then when the guy who wrote won the
award for The Pianist how he had a
history Lansky who had a hit you know
all about without him being you know
useless go to prison for raping at a
time you know 14 old-style 13 year old
and then before the conviction he flies
and just disappears yeah but then wins
award and once had anal sex Meryl
Streep's clapping everyone's giving them
around got her drugged up I believe and
had anal sex with her register quaalude
yeah yeah anal sex vaginal sex and and
somebody else she was 14 and then three
or four others also came out does the
pianist in Hollywood say bravo Bravo
well now that Harvey Weinstein signed a
petition to get him back in reinstated
and I said to have lunch people I go hey
that's great that yeah I get it man
blah blah blah if it was your 13 year
old daughter what would happen you have
to put yourself in those situations and
you know at the end of the day man well
this is this is sensitive to me I I know
I've had my I've known about this for a
long time but you know I just knowing
how hard this businesses and knowing for
women and seeing the heartbreak I've
seen and being in class and seeing you
can see whether they do it dude I've
seen that the did just that this [ __ ]
yeah and when you get a chance when you
get one chance and you only get one
chance in your [ __ ] life one chance
and you get your called up to discuss a
script and maybe a part in the movie
with the most powerful guy in Hollywood
and he's naked and jerking off at you or
whatever man oh man and yeah yeah you
know what you do keep quiet you do you
do if you're Ashley Judd or anybody else
including if you're famous and you know
why because you can ruin your career and
you know how it happens you just you
just don't hear about it you just don't
get calls did the phone just stops
raining nobody tells you that but it's
just really quiet and he goes I don't
hire her it says she's a she's trouble
okay
so you know
that I tend to be pretty yeah you know I
don't know if that that's the one thing
man it's a bad situation that's so
disturbing that last one on this I
didn't know this happened but Ben
Affleck he groped a girl during a TRL
Carson Daly but you know way back in the
days when they Total Request Live with
Carson Daly oh yeah I love that show
they're bringing her back by the way so
there's a girl in there it was during
one of the skits he just went up to her
and grabbed her left boob and then now
he's apologizing for that time but check
it out so the girl the girl that got
grabbed this is her response girls I'm
so impressed with you brave ones I've
had to laugh back VIN so I wouldn't cry
sending love after this case is it here
play it they don't show it though I
slaughtered yeah I mean a case you know
Casey Affleck has yeah little brother
yeah he's got he has issues too
Wow he got young trouble for a sexual
misconduct on set with two so sometimes
that you can get in trouble for like
things like that I actually make a
distinction between that's a little
different
yeah different I'm not a provement I
didn't see exact what it did that's a
little different your your little
different it's a little different or
maybe a lot different I'd have to see
the video it's a lot different and I you
know
alright blah blah blah you know but but
but I'm not as outraged by that just not
but you know also there's a lot of this
in Hollywood where you know I know two
pretty famous guys one of the guys you
would you like a lot and they mooned a
girl and they had to pay $100,000
because they got sued for sexual
misconduct so sometimes you know it's a
weird thing but burton claims been out I
don't want to give this too much time on
cam I just thought it let me see the
video
that's what we did and hugged her and
tweets your left boob yeah I mean we'll
come out sometimes I feel people come
out at these times for attention because
there's all this other stuff yeah well
I'm a victim it's also oppressed to yet
do you know what I mean like it feels
like I'm like you know that's kind of
where I go see that's the problem like
the real people who were actually you
know victims of this and then these be
right oh I did to Ben Affleck
head-butted me on accident and then
grabbed my breath all right man a little
different right
all right what else gets in and he might
have been drawn to you know he's saying
I'm saying he might be drunk you know he
might have been like he had butter he
might have run into a guy and it grabbed
her I mean I don't know yeah well no he
was in John he would get pretty drunk
for a long time so this one bar or
pourcel sports there's a two teachers
two teachers from the same school that
have sex scandals with their students so
that's the teacher it's a female I was
gonna say is that a female it's a female
oh yeah it is yeah so Christina Jacobson
arrested Monday and then Samantha Lee
was arrested on suspicion of having sex
with a student same school two teachers
from the same school trying to [ __ ] yeah
and they're boys again no girls people
like wow let's be so people like to [ __ ]
suspicion of oral copulation with person
under 18 years old and sexual
penetration with a foreign object
yeah that's frowned upon usually they're
hot though this one's are uh they were
great in the series funny they're great
hey grades looked D moral compass bad
judgment B intangibles B overall c-minus
but that's strictly a volume stat like
the kind of career numbers that got perp
Evelyn into the Hall of Fame separately
near these would rate a plug that's
ridiculous yeah that's terrible
alright there's a good news story all
right so a man helped the kidnap girl
and then the reward money he actually
gave it to her well that's cool
yes so girl was kidnapped by three dudes
house out of her house and she was gone
for like a month
Wow usually when they got someone for
you
just trouble yeah well that she was
missing for a long for a while and then
uh she somehow escaped when they're
getting food she swam across a river
that was near this guy's house she saw
he ended up going to work and then
having to go back home he thought it was
a deer yeah yeah three dudes saw her and
then saved her and then he just gave
this the reward money to her dad did
they catch the three dude got the
Pannell yeah yeah Jesus Christ and
that's even worse than what Harvey
Weinstein does that's your mo gage this
game that's horrible
you know what I mean like they're all
different grades of this [ __ ] just gets
worse and worse do you guys want to talk
about the fires at all or is that too
depressing right no I don't know I guess
it's way worse these are these things
always sneak up yeah I'm always like
fire as far as then I'm sitting you're
like why or well yeah you know Henry
cejudo was up there and lost his gold
medal burnt his feet and broke his ankle
Nick's cape in the fire damn yeah losses
going mental can you replace those how's
that work I don't know I think it's
tough to get them duplicated Alton Oh
what 560 people missing yes seven oh my
god so no more like 52,000 acres already
burned that's terrifying and you get
trapped by a fire and you basically die
they didn't know where to go
so the they're trying to escape and then
they're getting surrounded so super
scary oh my god
horrible oh my god that's scary how do
you do like is there a way to like I
don't [ __ ] know me so the there's
officials that tell you to go this way
that way but they're not always on time
and then are always right so that's how
people get lost that's scary man
super scary no that's awful
it's very bad yeah that's it all right
Jesus Christ did I mention cognitive
dissonance yes from the last podcast
like on air I did I'm I talked about it
what did you say about it in the
beginning just that that I was like I
might have talked about it do you know
what cognitive dissonance means it means
holding two contradictory like idea
good podcast yeah yeah it's okay to have
those things happen you got to talk
about the oh yes so we got the the
chinder shirts released in the night
5:00 p.m. Pacific only at t5k calm
chinder shirts which are brand new and
then we also have the certified diver
teased or restocked defects kake.com
speaking other shirts big shout out to
Jonathan musk musk ah Luke from kill the
box
kill the box CA for the certified dick
diver shirt and Dallas McIntyre from Pei
Canada which is Prince Edward Island huh
he's all I can't without that funny face
for the tender ship yep
appreciate the help fellas fans OHS give
us great ideas or help us that's
tributes dedications yeah they're all
gender certified dick diver tees restock
tonight tea fat Kade calm 5 p.m. Pacific
what do you see
I'll be on the San Jose improv starting
tomorrow Thursday Friday Saturday come
one come all
it's gonna be a good time tickets at t
f-- at kake.com or San Jose improv calm
um
this Sunday met the Hollywood improv red
band Rogen a bunch of people are on
there Greg Fitzsimmons that is Sunday
night at the Hollywood improv I am
marrying it tickets to the Hollywood
improv and then November 3rd I'm Colusa
casino November 10th and 11th I'm in
Nashville at Zanies that's just
announced Nashville zany's November 10th
and 11th then the 30th I'm in the Inland
Empire Ontario improv I forgot to
mention that I'm going to be the
following weekend in Calgary Canada
October they make Calgary Kansas nope
Calgary Canada I'll be there the
following weekend so I'll see you there
I think what 18 19 20 or someone cheap
at kake.com for all these lovely tickets
we love you guys 300 strong we have a
bunch more to go to now maybe oh yeah
brother we're ready we appreciate you
guys for making this what it is we love
you
this is the finer kid we're out